Fox News Propaganda's Tucker Carlson was instantly
destroyed on live TV after parroting the falsehood
that young children don't spread Corona virus,
which is a very dangerous and irresponsible
thing to say.
Tucker Carlson interviewed Fox News Dr. Marc
SIEGEL.
Marc SIEGEL has certainly had some cringeworthy
moments on Fox News over the years.
But credit to Marc SIEGEL.
He called out Trump for the bleach injection
fiasco and he instantly calls out Tucker Carlson
for this wild claim about kids and corona
virus.
Check it out.
Latest science.
There is new evidence that young children
do not spread the corona virus.
Not what we thought.
Dr. Marc SIEGEL is a Fox Monitor contributor
at NYU Langone.
Professor, Doctor, thanks for coming on tonight.
Tucker, I want to cut through the news and
get to the science of this, which is that
78 studies out of the United Kingdom show
that children, especially under the age of
10, are not very likely to get covered 19
or to spread it.
But one of the authors of that study says
he's being a little bit misinterpreted in
the Centers for Disease Control has said that
1 to 2 percent of the cases looking at one
hundred and fifty thousand cases were children
under the age of 18.
That's the real truth.
Here is and a China study showed that 90 percent
of children have asymptomatic cases.
So, Tucker, they appear to have a protein
in the lungs that protects them from severe
disease.
And almost all of the children who get this
are either asymptomatic or have mild cases.
But it is not true that children don't get
it.
And it is not true that they can't spread
it just much less likely than adults.
The look on Tucker's face, if you were watching
a look that says this is going horribly wrong,
that's worth Tucker's weight in gold.
Young children do not spread coronavirus.
Marc SIEGEL immediately says actually children
do spread it.
Tucker Carlson says this is the type of stuff
that when the disinformation spreads, it leads
to infections.
People are just mixing up different claims.
So let's look at them.
Are children less likely to get a symptomatic
case of the virus?
Yes, that's what the science currently says.
When children do get it, is their chance of
dying from it lower than adults?
Absolutely.
What the science says right now.
But children can spread it even when they
have it without symptoms.
This is one of the reasons that schools had
to be closed because one parent gets it.
Then a kid has it.
Then 10 kids have it and they bring it home
to their parents.
What Tucker Carlson is saying is just not
true.
There seems to be no corona virus.
Rumor that someone on Fox News is not willing
to spread.
Tucker was just complaining that shut downs
and stay at home orders were not decided with
science.
And then he casually says kids can't spread
the virus when, of course, they can.
And it's particularly important to understand
that the most dangerous spreaders can be those
without symptoms, because the kids have no
reason to think that they're sick and then
they become vast spreaders.
There was a study that finds actually that
kids zero to 6 have a very similar viral load
as those 12 to 19 and may maybe spreading
the disease just as effectively as high schoolers.
Now, what is certainly true is that if an
adult gets the virus and you contact trace,
there are probably fewer kids they've been
in touch with.
Unless you have kids or you work with children,
most of your contacts are going to be adults.
Maybe that's where something got mixed up.
But good for Dr. SIEGEL to immediately call
out this nonsense from Tucker Carlson.